what i actually used to tell a team is
like everyone is a chief engineer this
is extremely important
and that everyone must um understand how
the broadly speaking all the systems in
the vehicle work right um and so that
you
just so you don't have subsystem
optimization because this is naturally
what happens you can see the
organizational errors
um
in the like the the product errors
reflect the organizational errors so it
like essentially you'll see that that
there's an interface at
this point like if you've got whatever
departments you've got that will that
will be where your interfaces are right
and then instead of like getting rid of
something or
uh questioning the constraints
the
one department will
design to the constraints of the other
that the other department has given them
without
calling in to question those constraints
and saying those constraints are wrong
and you should actually take the
approach that the the constraints that
you're given are guaranteed to be some
degree wrong
guaranteed to be something you want huh
because the the counterpoint would be
that they were perfect right which is
never exactly as you say like what are
the what's the probably this is the
platonic idea or the perfect part zero
okay basically so you could question
your constraints it does not matter if
the person handing you those constraints
while a nobel prize there even einstein
is wrong some of the time right so
uh question your constraints this is
extremely important want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
you've got more inside you you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how billionaires think to
get some success advice from the top
enjoy
rule number two listen to criticism with
jeff bezos i talk a lot about
willingness to be misunderstood that's a
really important thing to have if you're
going to do anything new or different in
the world it is going to be
misunderstood sometimes by
well-meaning critics sometimes by
self-interested critics you'll get all
kinds
and
it's okay
it's all part of the process the only
way to avoid criticism altogether
is to be completely conventional in
everything you do
and
so how do you respond to the criticism
what do you do what's the right thing to
do
well i think
the first thing you do
is you ask
are the critics right you listen you ask
are they right or even if they're not
completely right
is there some piece of it that's right
that you can be inspired by
and then if you decide by the way that
the answer is no that you believe you
have conviction that what you're doing
is the right course
then no force in the world should be
able to move you
you should have a deep keel
but
if you decide that your critics that
there is something
then you should change
um and
i give you an example from the early
days of amazon of one where we refused
to change this we were small enough that
most people didn't pay much attention to
us or care about us i'm taking you way
back to like 1995 1996 we pioneered this
thing called customer reviews
and i got a letter one day from a
publisher
a book publisher that said hey
you must not understand your business
you're losing sales because you're
allowing negative customer reviews
on
the book detail pages why don't you just
put positive reviews
and i thought about this and i thought
no
he's wrong we don't make money when we
solve things we make money when we help
people make purchase decisions
it was a different framing
and so
getting to today's news
you know we listened to our critics and
we decided
the framing that we have been using all
these years is
competitive compensation we look at what
other job opportunities there are and
what the competitive compensation levels
are and we offer competitive
compensation and actually
non-competitive world leading benefits
packages but just competitive
compensation
and
so
in light of this you know thinking about
this trying to decide do we want to
change
we realize we just made a decision well
you can offer competitive competition or
you can decide to lead
and as soon as we framed it that way
we're like let's decide to lead it's
like i think people will follow and what
was it the critics said that caught your
eye
basically they were saying
they were if you read between the lines
because a lot of the specific criticism
was not correct but if you read between
the lines what they really wanted us to
do they said because you could also say
look there there's so many companies
there's all the fast food companies
there's you know the
baristas and there's you know like wait
a second why
are you focusing on us
but that what they're really saying is
we're focusing on you because you're a
leader
and we want you to lead
that's what they're actually saying and
as soon as you recognize it that way
instead of it feeling like criticism it
feels empowering they're asking us to
lead because we're a symbol of
an innovative
iconic company we're a gold standard for
innovation
we should lead rule number three empower
others with jack ma
entrepreneurs
are the most important element
to promote
to develop a society
and i think entrepreneurships
are very
constructive
points and elements of the society
in africa i think we need a three e's
e-government make the government
transparent
entrepreneurs
make them the heroes
[Applause]
education
make the people know what they want and
what they don't want
and as an entrepreneur in africa i went
to africa
four years ago
before i went there i know so i think i
know a lot about africa
when i arrived there i was surprised i
know so little about africa
and i promised myself in 10 years i will
visit every country in africa so i
visited five countries at least every
trip to africa in the past four years
and
and i think what i can do
is to empower the young people
young entrepreneurs
i went to kenya and met some of the
young entrepreneurs they are so smart
they are so good much smart than jack ma
in 1999.
they all have mobile phones
the thing is the entrepreneurs in africa
so different from entrepreneurs in most
of the other countries
most
entrepreneurs in the other countries
they always want they do entrepreneurs
they want to go ipo
these people they want to change africa
they want to change their lives
and when i was starting my business
nobody helped us
very few people today i think i have the
capability
i have the money
i have the resources
and i want to
go there
empower the entrepreneurs
if we can be able to discover and help
more jack masks mobile gates
more warren buffets
more steve
africa will be different
that's what i think
it's my great honor to be there and do
something
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four care enough to
try with oprah winfrey and it's true you
can't personally stop anybody from
walking into a school with an assault
rifle nor can you single-handedly ensure
that the rights that your mothers and
your grandmothers fought so hard for
will be preserved for the daughters that
you may someday have
and it'll take more than you alone to
pull 40 million americans out of poverty
but who will you be if you don't care
enough to try and what mountains could
we move i think what gridlock could we
eradicate if we were to join forces and
work together in service of something
greater than ourselves
you know my deepest satisfaction and my
biggest rewards have come from exactly
that
pick a problem any problem
and do something about it because to
somebody
who's hurting
something
is everything rule number five make a
difference with richard branson the only
reason we would go into a new sector is
if we felt it was being badly run by
other people so the reason we went into
trains was the government were running
trains uh british rail was dilapidated
trains um you know a miserable service
and we just felt um you know we could we
could go in we could get fantastic new
rail stock we could motivate the staff
and we could make a big difference and
so we took over
you know the busiest line in britain the
west coast main line
um and we've gone from 8 million
passengers to nearly 40 million
passengers and
and you know i think transformed the
experience for people um and
you know in every in every new sector
that we've gone into we we we've we've
seen
you know a gaping gap in the market
where the big guys have not been doing
it very well and
where we can come in and you know shake
up an industry rule number six make an
effort with mark cuban what's made you
successful i have all these stupid
little sayings that i tell myself all
the time or tell employees or whatever
and one of them is the one thing in life
that you can control
is your effort
and i always worked my ass off
always
you know first and last out i went seven
years when i started my first company
without a vacation
um i lived like i was broke because i
was and
obviously today i still do um
yeah
i don't know why me in terms of why i'm
here and somebody else isn't but i've
always just tried to bust my ass and be
smart about it and i'll keep learning
and trying to improve and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is lead by example
with grant cardone in my environment
what happens in our environment the
reason we're growing is because the code
of ethics
is
we push
we don't want lazy around us we have a
lot of fun okay but when we're pushing
when we're pushing to get the deal done
and that starts with the leadership
you know here here i am four days we've
been here
i haven't been in the ocean yet
you know i haven't done the little
things that go across the ocean what are
those called uh uh jet skis the jet skis
i haven't jumped out of the plane even
though everybody
by the way i'd love to skydive and i
probably will come come back in scotland
but i haven't done that because
the region's asking something of me
right and if i'm like i'm too busy i'm
i'm riding camels today great experience
and i will have it but i have to set
priorities in my life
the people around me know that i'm going
to take the work before i'm going to
take
the the the
yeah yeah
the leisure yeah
uh granted so pay the price today right
yeah the price and i can pay any price
tomorrow
haven't bought the stock you're an
admirer of jeff bezos that a listing of
the richest people in america came out
he's number one i think your friend bill
gates is number two you're number three
so you can see what he's done in myriad
ways
and of course the question is
how come you haven't bought amazon is
there still time to buy would you still
buy it oh i i always admired
jeff i mean i met him 20 years ago or so
and and
and
i thought it was something special but i
didn't realize you could go from books
to what what's happened there no i i
mean he had a vision
and executed in an incredible way
something that
it would not have
you know that
but there's a lot of games i miss i
would have missed you know i would have
missed microsoft even if i got to know
bill
earlier or something those just aren't
my games i don't worry about the things
that i miss that are outside my circle
of competence
of evaluating i i do i have missed
things that were within my circle
and that's a terrible mistake those are
my biggest mistakes you haven't seen
them
and but i don't
it's not a mistake because i miss
netscape or something like that at all
i would say that maybe five percent of
the companies or 10 of the companies at
most are within an area of my circle of
confidence there's something i should be
able to understand if you buy a business
if you buy a farm you know you go up and
look
you know every couple weeks to see how
far the corn is up and you know you
worry too much about whether somebody
says this is going to be a year of low
prices because exports are being
affected or anything like that you know
you buy a farm and you hold it for i've
got one farm that i bought in the 1980s
and my son runs it but
i've been there once you know i mean it
it it doesn't grow faster if i go and
stare at it you know i can't cheer for
it you know more effort more effort or
something like that and i know there's
going to be some years when prices are
going to be good and some when the
prices aren't going to be good i know
there's years when yields will be better
than others
but about the farm and and
if
it just doesn't i don't care about
economic predictions on it or anything
of the sort i do care that over
over the years it's well tended to and
in terms of rotating crops and i hope
yields get better which they generally
have
in fact
that farm
100 years ago would have probably
produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre
now in a good year you know it'd be 200
i mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices go
back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little is because we've just
gotten better and better at whether it's
cotton or whether it's it's corn or soy
beans or
all kinds of things
and you and i have benefited from that
and so apple's kind of like a farm
well it's a it's a long term investment
and and
if you owned
if you own the the best auto dealership
in town uh the best brand and had
somebody
good running it you wouldn't drop by
every day and say you know how many
people have come in today or you know i
think interest rates are going up a
little maybe that'll slow down our sales
or anything no
you buy it knowing there's 365 days a
year and you're going to own it for 20
years so that's 7 300 days and you know
they're gonna things are going to be
different from day to day and year to
year you shouldn't buy it at the
day-to-day stuff i haven't had any
existential crisises knock on wood i
find i don't want to jinx anything
um
but we've had a lot of uh
kind of dramatic events i remember
um there early on
we only had 125 employees
when barnes and noble who the big united
states bookseller
opened their online website to compete
against us barnesandnoble.com we'd had
about a two year window we opened in 95
they opened in 97.
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be destroyed by this much
larger company we had 125 employees
and
60 million dollars a year in annual
sales 60 million with an m
and that
and barnes noble at the time had 30 000
employees
and about 3 billion dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were very negative about
amazon and the one that's most minimal
or memorable was just amazon.toast
and
and so i called an all hands meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and because
it was so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor that literally everybody's
parents were calling and saying you know
are you okay is it's usually the moms um
calling and asking their children are
you gonna be okay so and i said look you
know it it's okay to be afraid um but
don't be afraid of our competitors
because they're never gonna send us any
money be afraid of our customers and if
we just stay focused on them in
in in in instead of
obsessing over this big competitor that
we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to double down on the customer
satisfying them not just satisfying them
delighting them first of all
you don't need college learning learn
stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning um
there there is
a value that colleges have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's
is can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of
sort of annoying homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
get it done
you know that's
that's like
the main value of college and then also
you know if you if you probably want to
hang around with a bunch of people your
own age for a while instead of going
right into the workforce
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning we are not
a company that uh normally china call we
call ourselves a company running a
platform a company that is running an
ecosystem
we are almost everywhere people say jack
you know you are in the b2b and b2c and
you're calling c2b on a finance and
online payment logistics cloud computing
you are everywhere
not because we are greedy not because we
want to do it because we have to do it
if we cannot if we do not do it china
e-commerce in the years will collapse
i remember nine years ago when i started
the alipay people said jack don't touch
the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison
and i we taught ourselves if we don't do
it
the china e-commerce were always like a
like a chat
room everybody said it's a good thing
and yeah i don't pay you don't get the
things so i say well put me in the
prison let's make sure that alipay the
payment solution works and people say
the payment solution is such a stupid
idea it's an escrow service
i pay you hold the money and you get the
things
you pay the money if you don't get the
things you want return the money they
say it's a stupid product
and i say as long as they solve the
problem i like stupid things you know
let's make stupid things smart keep on
improving every day i never thought it
would be successful i never thought
we could survive for 18 years
and then we made it
the only thing that today we should do
is share the experience and know how
especially share the mistakes suffers
with others
my
thinking is that
you guys remember
if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they make
don't listen to that
there are a lot of reasons behind it
just like
i remember the first time harvard
business school came to us say jack
we want to write a
case study for you
yes yes 2001 or 2000.
they came they spent one week and they
write a report and i read no i said this
is not me
and this is this is you that's no this
is not us he said this is you so the
makeup is signed
and the case study go up and they
started teaching a lot of universities
the next five years they invited me to
go to the case study and they always
find a competitor of my company and if
after every
case study alibaba would die that
company will succeed
all the students agree and
actually every five years all the
competitors die we still survive
so how can you study this kind of a
successful story
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are you will
encount these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come this suffer comes
you know how to deal with it
how to face it i
i the book i want to write
if i
if i want
if i can
it's alibaba one thousand one mistake
the real way i think you you actually
achieve intellectual property protection
is by innovating fast enough if your
rate of innovation is high
then you don't need to worry about
protecting vip
because
other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure
your rate of innovation is fast
speed is really speed of innovation is
what is what matters um
and i do i do say this to my teams like
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go innovation per year if you
want to say like is is what matters not
innovation
absent time because if you wanted to
make say
100 improvement in something
and that took 100 years or one year
that's
radically different
so
it's like what is your rate of
innovation that that matters and is the
rate of innovation
is that accelerating or decelerating
and a weird thing happens when companies
get big is that most companies
or organizations the bigger they get
they tend to
get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
uh
is not
there for innovation
um
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation the incentive
structure must be aligned with that
that's fundamental we're very interested
in physical stores and we haven't i've
been asked for years
um
we ever opened physical stores literally
20 years have been asked the question
and i always say yes but only when we
have
a differentiated
uh differentiated offering something
that's not me too
um because that space physical storage
is so well served if we offer a me to
product offering it's not gonna work
we're and it's also just we're not very
good at that most of the whenever we've
tried
dabbling in something that's a me tooth
service we tend to get
beaten it doesn't work we're
our culture is much better at pioneering
and inventing and so we have to have
something that's different and that's
what amazon go is it's completely
different the amazon bookstore
completely different and we have ideas
about how to merge prime and whole foods
to make that those are still rolling out
you haven't seen them yet but to make to
use amazon prime to make whole foods a
very differentiated experience and so
what we're going to be able to do is
take some of our resources some of our
technical technological know-how and and
expand the whole foods mission
they have a great mission which is to
bring nourishing food to everybody
organic nourishing food to everybody
and um but you know we have a lot to
bring to that table in terms of
resources but also in terms of
operational excellence and in terms of
technology know-how i would
i would like to tell you of
two women
that
each sold the business
to berkshire hathaway uh to me actually
for many many many millions of dollars
both of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was everything they
had in the world
and one of them was a woman
who landed in seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck
the tag said
fort dodge iowa
the red cross
got her to fort dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who had come
to the country a couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years
and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to omaha
so they came to omaha
in 1919
and there she found a
small colony of russian jews so she
started feeling more at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school that day
and this woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father
50 at a time she sold used clothing to
do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she'd saved 2 500
she went to chicago
and she bought what she could have
furniture her dream had always been to
open
a furniture store
and this woman without who had never
gone to school one day in her life
with 2 500
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she sold to me
in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
[Applause]
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin
lived while she she worked for me until
she was 103. and
then i
said then she retired and she died the
next year which is a lesson to all the
berkshires managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b
with her 2500
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew she cared about her customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business the
african desert every green is that the
ecosystem is not controlled by lions and
elephants
the ecosystem is controlled by the
insects in the mud
last century the company the big the
better so everybody want to be big
company the powerful company this
century from now on a good company is
more important than a powerful company
when you compete with become i think in
past 20 years we've been competing with
any company
lots of companies in china
but i learned one thing
no matter how strong an elephant is
if you're an ant if you hide yourself
well
an elephant cannot kill you
you can kill the elephant if you're in a
better way
it's about your thinking the secret
sauce of amazon where there are several
principles at amazon but the number one
thing that has made us successful by far
is obsessive compulsive focus on the
customer as opposed to
obsession over the competitor and i talk
so often to
other ceos
and
some other ceos and also
founders and entrepreneurs and i can
tell that even though they're talking
about customers they're really focusing
on competitors and it is a huge
advantage to any company if you can stay
focused on your customer instead of your
competitor in my apartment where we
started 18 founders
and we aim high we have a dream we say
we want to make become the top 10
internet companies or websites in the
world guys at that time we are ranking
several million
names who is it well be number 10 or the
top 10 of the world
we want to make this company last 102
years and we don't know where is our pay
next month
well when you are poor
if you have a dreams you'll never feel
poor
you know what we are doing
so after we never say we will we will
win next year or we win tomorrow we say
we will win in 10 20 years
19 years past today we are the top 10
websites com internet companies in the
world
you know we all have adversity in our
lives
i i would i would i doubt if you really
you know if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to
um
there's no lack of adversity and
the uh and by the way that's good
because it's what teaches us how to get
back up you fall down you get back up it
always happens
and
you know you get certain
gifts in life and you want to take
advantage of those
but you
i guess my advice on adversity and uh
success
would be
to
be proud not of your gifts
but of your hard work and your choices
so you know you may be the kinds of
gifts you get you know you might be
really good at math it might be really
easy for you that's a kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat
that's a choice you can't really be
proud of your gifts
because they were given to you
you can be grateful for them and
thankful for them
and but your choices
you choose to work hard
you choose to do hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of i don't need to be
in washington to figure out what the
washington post
newspaper is worth and i don't need to
be in new york to figure out what some
other company is worth it's it's it's
simply it's an intellectual process
and the less the less static there is in
that intellectual process really the
better off you are what is the
intellectual process intellectual
processes
is
defining your level defining your area
of competence and valuing businesses
and then
within that area of competence
finding whatever sells at the at the
cheapest price in relation to value and
there are all kinds of things i'm not
competent to value but there are a few
that i am confident
have you ever bought a technology
company no i really haven't
in 30 years of investing not one i
haven't understood any of them so you
haven't ever owned for example
never owned ibm
marvel's company i mean a sensational
company but i haven't owned ibm
and so here is this technological
revolution going on and you're not going
to be a participant going right past me
is that all right with you it's okay
with me
i don't have i don't have to make money
in every game i mean i don't know what
cocoa beans are gonna do
i don't you know there are all kinds of
things i don't know about and that may
be too bad but uh you know why should i
know all about them i haven't worked
that hard on them in securities business
you literally every day have thousands
of the major american corporations
offered you
at a price and a price that changes
daily
and you don't have to make any decisions
you have to make
nothing is forced upon you so you there
are no called strikes in the business
the pitcher just stands there and throws
balls at you
and uh if you're playing real baseball
and it's between the knees and the
shoulders you either swing or you got a
strike call on you if you get too many
call i know you're out in the securities
business
you sit there and they throw
us steel at 25 and they throw general
motors at 68 and you don't have to swing
at any of them they may be wonderful
pitches to swing at but if you don't
know enough you don't have to swing
and you can sit there and watch
thousands of pitches and finally get one
right there where you want it something
that you understand and then you swing
and so you might not swing for six
months you might not swing for two years
many aspiring entrepreneurs even in this
room struggle to find their initial idea
how do you constantly find ways to
invent new products and where does your
inspiration come from um you know i
um
i mean i think of a lot of ideas at
traffic lights
i think of them all the time in
different places and i think it's part
of just being hyper observant
i um i like to
find white space i pay attention to what
are things that haven't evolved and why
you know like there's certain things in
our society that
updates itself and changes and and you
know constantly and then there's certain
things that it's not and so i'll ask
myself questions all day every day it's
just the way my brain works like i could
even be looking at a table and be like
why is the table like that when was the
table first created is that the actual
best design for a table or could there
be something different and you know what
spanx went into men's and that was
randomly how that happened was because i
got curious that the man's undershirt
was created in 1918 and no one had paid
any attention to it since it was
literally the same thing and so i just
you know talked to my brother and my
husband about it and their undershirts
that the necks stretched out or they
were boxy and bulky under clothes and i
thought oh i'm just going to add a
little bit of lycra to the cotton
undershirt for men and so the neck won't
stretch out and i'm going to taper it in
at the waist my assistant who's my right
hand lisa she's been my right hand for
16 years can attest to this but i have
99 pages i don't know why it's 99 but
she told me the other day it's 99 pages
single spaced type of ideas
i need one more idea so um i i think of
ideas constantly on airplanes and car
you know talking to somebody and i email
it to myself and then i just keep them
and log them people like us
we are getting used to be criticized
we are getting used to be said
no people say
no to you
when people say yes to you
we really appreciate because it's not
you know why people should say yes to
you you have to prove
so as an entrepreneur
you have to get used to be
challenged have to get used to being
said no by the other people by the found
by the investors by your customers by
the people but this
this is the opportunity when everybody
believe it you have no chance when only
few people believe it you believe it you
prove it that's your chance kfc has
refused to hire you
so
uh
with all this
know
how at the end of the day what has been
the driver which has made you who you
are
yeah i wish people can say yes to me
but if they say yes i have no choice i
have to accept it
and
of course you're not happy when people
say no
have a good sleep wake up try it again
it's always my fault not the other
people's part why you can convince
people
if you cannot prove it
but the thing is that
very important there are two group of
people you have to convincing first
group people your team
they believe in you
they trust in you and they believe the
things we agreed together
and second is uh your customers they
really love your products
and investors it's okay there's this
culture in silicon valley that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting a startup
and
my goal when i realized that i had a
company was to get it to be a good
company as quickly as possible right and
kind of get out of what you'd call the
like risky startup phase where you are
just like constantly about to die and
where you could get to a point where you
can actually do some interesting things
and make make a lot of more interesting
bets
and um
so i don't know i never read a lot of
the literature on this and i mean maybe
if i had then i wouldn't have made so
many mistakes but so i don't know if
like if learning for me is the right way
to go on this but i mean but it did
i think your model must have come from
somewhere though even if it was even if
you it was unintentional right like were
you influenced by peter thiel or sean
well yes people see all these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before i'm
talking about
yeah right yeah but he was massively
influential on my thinking right i mean
like a lot of the
uh the early lessons that i took on how
to think about strategy came from peter
and sean and um i did pay a lot of
attention when i was growing up to
microsoft i thought i mean i grew up you
know using you know windows 3.1 and then
windows 95 and i just thought that those
were like the most unbelievable things
ted williams wrote a book called the
science of hitting and ended he had a
picture of himself at bat and the strike
zone broken into i think 77 squares
and he said if he waited for the pitch
that was really in his sweet spot he
would bat 400 and if he had to swing at
something on the lower corner he would
probably bat 235
and in investing i'm in a no called
strike business which is the best
business you can be in
i can look at a thousand different
companies and i don't have to be right
on every one of them or even 50 of them
so i can pick the ball i want to hit
and the trick in investing
is just to sit there and watch pitch
after pitch go by and wait for the one
right in your sweet spot and if people
are yelling swing you bum ignore them
there's a temptation for people to act
far too frequently in stock simply
because they're so liquid
over the years you develop a lot of
filters and i do know what i call my
circle of competence so i i stay within
that circle the allowance when i was a
little boy was a nickel a week but i
like the idea of having a little more
than a nickel a week to work with and i
went into business very early
i started selling coca-cola door-to-door
i sold gum door-to-door or sold saturday
in post liberty magazine ladies home
journal you name it
[Music]
i think i enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
but i like being my own boss
that's one thing i like about delivering
papers
[Music]
i could arrange the route i wanted
nobody was bothering me at five or six
in the morning
[Music]
i was delivering 500 papers a day and i
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding
that penny's turned into something else
everything i've ever done
has started
small
amazon started
with a couple of people and
blue origin started with
five people
and uh the budget of bloorigin was very
very small now the budget of blue
origins approaches a billion dollars a
year and next year it'll be more than a
billion dollars in amazon it literally
was 10 people today it's half a million
people but you it's hard to remember for
you guys but for me it's like yesterday
i was driving the
packages to the post office myself
and
hoping one day we could afford a
forklift and so
so for me i've seen small things get big
and it's part of this day one mentality
i like treating things as if if they're
small you know amazon even though it is
a large company
i wanted to have the heart and spirit of
a small one i spent an unusual amount of
time
with my
uh grandparents and especially with my
grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south texas
and i would spend my summers there from
age four to sixteen and they when i was
four they were taking me for the summer
to kind of give my parents a break
you know sort of because they were so
young
um and it was useful i was a handful i'm
sure
and uh and anyway
he he he he created the illusion for me
when i was four years old that i was
helping him
on the ranch which of course could not
have been true
but i believed it and um and then as by
the time i was 16 of course i was
actually helping on the ranch i you know
i could i can fix prolapsed cattle i can
you know we did all of our own
veterinary work
some of the cattle even survived
and we fixed windmills and laid you know
water pipelines and built fences and
barns and fixed that fixed the bulldozer
that you guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about that lifestyle and
about my grandfather is he did
everything himself you know he didn't
call that if one of the animals was sick
he figured out what to do himself and
uh so what does it mean no delegation
being resourceful i think is the you
know that you can always you can't if
there's a problem there's a solution
people often ask me
what it takes to start a business what
is the key ingredient how did i how did
i start the business and how did we grow
to about 20 million
20 million dollars in sales so quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're going to invent
the the better mousetrap they're going
to come up with new software new
hardware and more often than not it
seems like they spent their millions
before they thought through their idea
but when we talk about new companies and
growth and success there really is only
one common ingredient across any type of
business whether it's oil or computers
or soft or anything and that key
ingredient is customers
without customers whether you're
starting a business running a business
expanding a business you don't have a
business
there is no business
customers are the key ingredient to get
those profits
you gotta have the customers and you
gotta have happy customers
that's the bottom line
you know micro solutions we think we've
been going and growing and it's
impossible not to have growing pains
it's impossible not to make mistakes we
screw up all the time
and you know it doesn't bother me as
president if i have if i have an
employee
who you just didn't do something right
just made a mistake
it's good
because if you're not making mistakes
you're not trying hard enough you know
these things i'm saying they're not
unique they're not things that i just
thought up in some some miracle brook
you know things when i talk to people in
our company when i talk to people about
our company i never have unique thought
i can't remember i don't know that i
ever did i can't remember if i ever will
or don't expect ever to there's no magic
formulas to customer service there's no
magic formula to doing things right
these these sayings that you hear me say
are things that i've read elsewhere and
just regurgitate that
but how many people do that
you know we all know the golden rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
and that's nice you know but do you do
it
but even more importantly than your
golden rule what about the lover's role
join others as you would love to have
them do unto you
that's what we try to stress at micro
solutions that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that is an acquaintance that
you liked okay you're going to offer
them coffee
you're going to offer them a donut and
that's really what you expect you know
if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances but when you
leave their house
it was nice
if you go that fine if you don't go back
fine that's the way customers look at
businesses
if i go back fine if i don't go back
fine
you know they say that 80 of the people
who have a problem tell at least 10
people
only 10 of the people who had a good
experience tell anybody
and it's the same way when you go to
visit an acquaintance
and when people come to try to do
business with micro solutions i hope i
pray and i try to convey to each and
every one of our people
that we give them a reason
to want to come back
we give them a reason to do a good
morning rap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do it to you
recently you shared in a press
conference
that one of facebook's focuses for the
next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood
than be liked
will you just share what you meant by
that
yeah i mean
look it's
let's be real here i'm not i'm not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've
been planning for this i'm excited about
it and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds so i mean
look when when i got started with
facebook i was 19
and um and i there were so many parts
about building a company that i didn't
know right i didn't i didn't know
anything about hiring or managing or
building a company and i certainly
didn't
really know that much about you know how
to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i mean i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
um
and uh
you know my experience you know kind of
growing up and running the company is
you know went out talked about what we
did
say some stupid things get called out
for it and get like kind of go into a
into a shell right and and uh end up
being really cautious about how we
communicate
so
you know it kind of it worked out okay
for a while for the company because
you know we we built products that a lot
of people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well i
think in spite of the fact that we were
communicating quite poorly about what we
were doing but broadly speaking for a
long time uh the basic approach was okay
let's try to not like
do anything that's going to be too
offensive right and and we'll kind of
explain what we're doing in broad
strokes and talk about the mission of
what we're doing which is something that
i really believe in helping to build
community and and bring people closer
together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that
some of the principles that we believe
in that that um that are increasingly
controversial in the world and i just
think that we
for one don't have that luxury anymore
for two uh i i think that that kind of
led for a while to a sentiment towards
the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if you're not kind of out
there standing for things that uh that
people care about then you know it's not
possible for people to feel that
strongly about what you're doing but so
now you know i i've just i've tried to
change our approach more recently you
know i went out and i in georgetown
last year i gave this speech around our
principles around free expression
and you know that's just one of the
areas that i really feel like is under
attack right now i think when dreams
start to brew in us or when there's like
a seed planted in us where we have this
dream it kind of started that way where
i was like like it was like a little
inkling like wait a minute if i if i
could figure out how to
launch how to create a product that
works for me i better help a lot of
other people and then i would kind of
like silence that dream and i would my
head would take over oh jamie you have
no connections you have barely any money
you don't know anything about the beauty
industry
and you're you're in your dream job
right now right and so it was i went
through that battle and i think everyone
listening to us right now probably like
really if they get still they probably
know right now
if there's a dream on their heart or or
something they know
what they're supposed to create or go
after or offer the world or start
painting again or start dancing right
they kind of know
um but sometimes our head talks
ourselves out of our lives absolutely
dreams
is spanx started way before i cut the
feet out of my pantyhose that's the
sound bite in the press that everybody's
talked about for almost 20 years but it
actually started
fundamentally on when i was 16 i worked
on mindset for myself and i'm such a
believer in mindset is almost everything
and it just happened to be a set of
circumstances i was riding my bike with
one of my best friends at 16 and she was
run over by a car and killed in front of
me
and then a few months later my dad left
home and my parents separated and
ultimately got divorced and when my dad
moved out he came into my bedroom and he
handed me a cassette tape series called
how to be a no limit person by wayne
dyer
and he said sweetie i wish i discovered
this when i was your age instead of the
age of 40 and then he moved out
and so i started listening to this how
to be a no limit person which was
talking about visualization law of
attraction um not caring about what
other people think about you the fear
you know not being consumed by the fear
of failure and it just the clouds parted
for me and i thought you know i've spent
a lot of time being taught what to think
but no one's really teaching me how to
think
and at 16 that was so incredibly
important so in this digital platform
it's kind of passing on a lot of these
insights that deal with mindset that i
think is the real reason that spanx
exists so what what do you think the
three keys to your success are
well i think a lot of it goes back to
those values right i mean the values
often come from the founder the person
running the company so i think i believe
those things probably the most strongly
of people at the company
um yeah move fast be bold right um focus
on impact and i think um
you know i think long-term focus is a
really important part of this and we've
had a lot of opportunities to optimize
for the shorter term whether it's in
selling the company or doing different
products that would have benefited us in
the short term but not optimized for the
long-term impact then um
and i just think you know opportunities
like this don't come around that often
so when you get one i feel like you
almost have a duty to see it through and
build it to be what it can be even after
you had done your thing there was still
an eighth course to make sure that yahoo
itself was on track do you know what
that was about yeah they were screwing
everything up you know i mean look they
had they had an opportunity to dominate
um streaming media they also owned at
the same time the patent to cost per
click yeah
right now google's entire business to
this day
is built around
pay-per-click rather they're not called
pay-per-click yeah
so they had the entire patent for
pay-per-click
had they just said sorry google
you can't use it
there would be no google
instead they said yeah 133 million
dollars and give us some stock
they were just too nice
right which blinded them in a lot of
respects and i remember walking in with
a 32 million dollar sale
saying okay we're going to do streaming
we're going to sell all this company's
content you know it's worth 32 million
dollars for us and it's going to pre-up
these other potential competitors and um
i forget if it's jerry or tim whoever
said no
we don't work that way we don't preempt
competition we just leave it open
i'm like okay it's time for me to go buy
a basketball team
that's they just they just didn't see
these things and i mean it's a lesson in
your businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass
and you have to figure out how to kick
your your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself and your own
business about what your frailties are
someone else is going to find them yahoo
didn't get that yahoo just thought you
know what we're just going to continue
moving forward and we'll just compete
with everybody else and you know there's
we have no other problems
didn't quite work out for them did it
the packaging what am i going to do for
the packaging i knew i thought as a
consumer i didn't know anything else i'd
never actually taken a marketing class
either in my life but i knew as a
consumer i was frustrated i was going
into the hosiery departments and
everything looked the same it was the
same beige package or the same way
package with the same half naked woman
that had been on there for 30 years
and
i couldn't tell what i was buying so i
said to myself i'm going to do this
different i want it to be my favorite
color red
no one had ever done red in the hosiery
space before i wanted to be bold stand
out i knew that if i got a chance to be
on the shelf with no money to advertise
it had to jump out and say i'm new i'm
different try me so i put three animated
illustrated cartoon women on the package
which had also never been done before
there had only ever been photography on
these poetry packages i was working on
it every night after work on my friend's
computer she had just finished um
graphic design school so i would come
home and we would sit side by side and i
was cutting out lips and eyes and i was
very you know excited about how to make
it design wise i wanted it to feel like
you were buying a present for yourself
instead of a commodity that we dreaded
when you get a 1 000 on your s.a.t
i probably got like a 980. i've
convinced myself that i broke a thousand
becomes a survival skill it's a
necessity to get into the door to
interview to sell everything for me
revolved around creativity so one day at
the recording studio i walk in and
there's a cassette sitting on the music
board
and it's the cassette that changed my
life
the cassette was by an artist a rat
pioneer named dana dane dana was a
brooklyn-born artist his first album was
one of my favorite albums and this was
an advanced copy in the late 80s that
nobody
nobody had
sitting there i wanted to listen to it
so i asked the engineer if i could
borrow the cassette and i would bring
the cassette back after i listened to it
he said sure
a couple of days later i'm on my way to
los angeles to visit a friend i'm
listening to it in my sony walkman if
anyone remembers those sony walkman yeah
and when i'm on the plane i read that
the owner of delicious finals favorite
artist this is a big label tone lok and
young his favorite artist is dana dane
so when i land in california i cold
called delicious vinyl i get all the way
up to the assistant of this guy she has
no idea what i'm talking about i'm
talking very fast like a new yorker i
have dana's tape i know mike's a fan of
dayna
she puts me on hold
she comes back two minutes later and she
says dana
if you can be here at two o'clock mike
ross would love to meet you
dana will be there at two o'clock
two o'clock comes the dana's a
brooklyn-born guy like i said
african-american goldtooth
not me
i pushed the
now a good friend of mine though
pushed the button they said i said hey
i'm dana here from micros oh
mike is expecting you dana come right in
i walk in they escort me into the office
loc's record young's record he's got
this funky candle going they sit me down
i'm sitting there i'm waiting no idea
what's going to happen in walks
mike ross
and says to me not as politely who in
the world are you
there's a famous quote by harry truman
if you can't convince him
confuse them
it works so far
so i start saying oh i work at the same
studio as dana i know you're a fan of
dana he must be late he has an advanced
tape
can i put in my cassette that i did at
day in the studio you have a cassette
what do you do
i rap
huh put it in
put in my cassette and he says the four
words that every artist struggling
artist wants to hear
who's your lawyer
i don't have a lawyer i have a dad so i
give him my dad's number my dad owns a
plumbing
my dad owns a plumbing supply house in
mineola
i call my father when we leave i said
dad i think i just got a record deal if
someone calls you
we got our foot in the door we're gonna
figure the rest out later get all the
documents
that started a journey of getting my
foot in the door
and figuring it out later a key thing in
creativity starting the process trusting
the process and letting it evolve
because if you don't get your foot in
the door if you don't start
nothing happens i did it with a company
called marquee jet we sold it to warren
buffett i did it with our company's eco
coconut water we sold it to coca-cola
the process of me cutting the feet out
of my pantyhose while trying to get the
prototype made before i launched it was
two years so there was a year solid of
me driving in north carolina on the
weekends and at night or taking time off
from work to go and work on the
prototype get it made i learned so many
things that i didn't know as a consumer
it had never dawned on me you know that
men were making all of our undergarments
so i learned very quickly that the
industry had been taking an average
waistband size between a small and an
extra large and putting the same
waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not working
we're really uncomfortable
and they were doing it to cut cost and
production so i immediately changed that
in a spanx waistband a size small gets a
small medium gets a medium and so on
makes perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord inside the
waistbands that had been there forever
well we had made so many advancements in
yarns that they no longer needed the
rubber cord but no one had stopped to
say do we still need to put this so i
immediately took the rubber cord out of
it and another thing i learned was the
way that they were doing sizing was just
so blew me away they would figure out a
size by putting them on plastic forms
and they would all put it on a plastic
form they had different size forms and
they would stand back with their
clipboards and go
yep that's a size medium
and i'd lean in and i go
ask her how she feels
so at spanx we put our product on women
my mother my grandmother who's 90
my sister-in-law cassie i mean all of my
friends the girls at spanx we're testing
it on real women and we want to test it
more than two seconds to say yep that
looks like a medium we we have people
wear it for a week wash it tell us if it
rolled did it move did it stay in place
how did you feel very concerned with
spanx garments and how they made you
feel what do you think it'll take for
you to get over insecurity moving
forward
i'm not trying you're not trying i'm not
trying to
i thought you said if you could get rid
of it you'd be able to do bigger the
unbelievable but but it's not it's not
it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of being a
human being any more than i want to get
rid of my arms you know or my legs or
my arms and my legs my body my body is a
limitation
yeah you know so um how do you manage it
better than like for people that are
saying i you know i want a 10x but i
always have insecurity and fear that i'm
going to fail and people are going to
show up and yeah the deal is going to
i'm going to go broke
how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear yeah it's not stop
it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know they it's calling me
says hey come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it lean
into it come play with me okay so i
either have fear because it's really
dangerous
and stupid
or like physically dangerous yeah like
let me get to the edge of this thing i'm
gonna get on the other side of that
thing i'm probably gonna be scared yeah
now
why am i gonna be scared though
like because i don't know what it feels
like to fall
you know this many floors and hit yeah
maybe it does maybe there's no big deal
about maybe dying is not even a big deal
right but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so
you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because you
have the experience i don't have the
experience man yeah this this is the
problem and you're not gonna have the
experience if you don't move through the
fear
and
a lot of people do it once and then they
don't do it again you gotta like
it's not going away yeah it's just gonna
you're gonna get used to
you're gonna get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't man
but you just
wear into them do you remember how much
your first server cost you said oh yeah
no eighty-five dollars eighty-five
dollars yeah no and i remember that
because um that was the gating factor
for us launching new schools i i mean we
had this philosophy from the very
beginning that we didn't wanna be this
project it wasn't even a company at the
very beginning but we didn't want to be
burning a lot of money right we weren't
planning on raising a lot of money we
didn't want to be one of these things
that raised a bunch of money and you
know was losing a bunch of money and
then decided that we'd somehow pull it
through at the end and
um so you know so
85 for the first server put ads on the
site and the the ads at the beginning
were uh we just were running some kind
of ad network and do you remember what
the first ad was
um
no i don't um
i don't know how did you get ads um
this was eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning and
um
you know but basically i mean so it was
the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server um and um and eduardo worked
on selling more ads or making a deal so
that we can get an ad network so that
way we can we can make more money but
then whenever we had more money we
rented another 85 a month server and we
kind of went from there and um i don't
know just it's just an interesting way
of seeing you never spent money you
didn't have in the beginning not in the
beginning no and then i mean even that
was the constraint on your growth rate
how many new 85 dollars is you could get
yeah and i mean it was actually good
because i i mean you know sometimes it's
really nice to have the time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems yeah you know
the idea was they were they grew quickly
and it was really hard for them to scale
and um you know the fact that we could
kind of go college by college and and
kind of optimize the service and make it
more efficient and offer new features
but make sure that they worked um i
think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who'd never built a
company before we never built any
large-scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly then facebook did grow quickly
but i think it took a year for us to get
a million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast but um and and i
think it is but
it wasn't as quick as a lot of things
grow today and i think actually having
that time to bake it was really valuable
on an individual level i think it is
always uh it's always really good if if
there's something that you're incredibly
passionate about and um and just sort of
are find to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the
one of the the the resolutions i came up
with
a number of years ago was to always uh
um value substance over status substance
over prestige um
and you know if i sort of was giving my
younger self advice on what to what to
do or how to how to think about um
your when's one's life i you know i
probably i think i you know um
i probably would still go to stanford um
you know i i might still go to law
school um but i'd ask i'd ask sort of
i'd ask a lot more questions why why i
was doing these things and i think
i think if i was honest about it
too much of it was driven by
by prestige and status and not quite
enough about
really the substance of of trying to
learn things and you know i had sort of
this i sort of just think of it as this
sort of crazy rolling quarter life
crisis and sort of culminated in this uh
in this you know big new york law firm
where you know from the outside
everybody wanted to get in from the
inside everybody wanted to get out
you know after i lasted seven months and
three days and after uh
and when i when i when i left one of the
people down the hall said you know it's
so reassuring to see you leave peter i
had no idea it was possible to escape
from alcatraz which which again uh and
you know and again i and all you had to
do was go through the front door but our
identity um people's identities get so
wrapped up in
the things they compete for that it was
inconceivable for people to actually do
that and and then the question was you
know well how had i ended up there why
had i not thought about that more and i
think it was
that i had taken too many of these
shortcuts of valuing sort of what was
prestigious what was conventional over
what i what i really want to do so i
think i think always substance over
status
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more amazing lessons from
billionaires check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there let failure be your friend
there are going to be times
of course
where you're going to win a lot a lot of
things are going to go your way